austria is to become the first country
in europe to make covid19 vaccines
mandatory by law and the country has
announced a full national lockdown from
monday
austria's chancellor alexander
schallenberg said the lockdown would run
for a maximum of 20 days
yesterday the country recorded more than
15 000 new cases of the virus setting a
new record high for daily positive tests
this comes as a fourth wave of the virus
is beginning to take hold in europe
austria had previously imposed
restrictions on the country's
unvaccinated population but will now go
into a full national lockdown
yesterday the german chancellor angela
merkel announced lockdown restrictions
for those who haven't received an
injection in areas struggling with a
high infection rate and limited hospital
capacity meanwhile here in the united
kingdom the government has added proof
of a third vaccination so-called booster
job to the nhs app
as a growing number of countries make it
a requirement for travel